[Applause]
during the presidential campaign little
Trump called NATO obsolete it may he
impose the tariff on European steel and
aluminum of sensibly on national
security grounds at the same time his
administration like all the previous
ones since the end of the Second World
War remains committed to the defense of
Europe there's military deployments in
Eastern Europe have increased in size
since from zero Eurasian and perhaps
surprisingly US sanctions against Russia
have been stronger than those adopted by
the European Union as the president is
headed to the NATO summit in Brussels on
the 11th and 12th of July the question
is how those two phases of
administration can be reconciled there
are real and legitimate issues at stake
free prosperous and secure Europe is
very much in the America's interest but
the United States cannot care about
European security more than Europeans do
a longtime US presidents have tried to
persuade the Europeans to invest more
into their defense without success maybe
do no drums bluster and abrasive manners
will bring results where diplomacy has
failed but don't hold your breath but
what do you think about the role America
has been playing in NATO it does know in
your comment also it has know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to more research and videos
from AEI